the s p 500 has hit another all-time
high
today is tuesday
yesterday was monday on monday it hit an
all-time high on tuesday hit an all-time
high it's hit an all-time high the s p's
hit an all-time high almost one out of
three days
in the market
out of the trading days in 2021 the s p
500 has hit an all-time high almost one
out of every three days
this week it's two for two
last week i think it was four for five
like
if this was a batting average the s p
500 would be in the hall of fame right
it just keeps hitting all-time high
after all-time high after all-time high
and so what that tells you is not only
is that a tailwind to a stock like
microstrategy but it's also showing you
asset prices are being inflated and if
those asset prices continue to go up
also the price of goods and services are
going to continue to go up and so we
have all-time highs in the s p 500 we
have all-time highs in the fed's balance
sheet again we were over 8.3 trillion
dollars
last week and then we have
all-time highs at least in the last
decade for cpi and we have 30-year highs
in core inflation everything is hitting
these high points and so uh if you think
of uh cpi for example it's not it's not
an all-time high it's an uh a 13-year
high um and then core is a 30-year high
you have to do something but to see the
s p 500 continue to do this i mean this
is a
parabolic may i say
curve here where it just seems like it
just continues to grow up and up and up
and up uh to the point where literally
it's on fire like it's like if you used
to play what was the uh video game where
it'd be like uh you're warming up and
all of a sudden once you hit three shots
in a row you just couldn't miss from
anywhere in the game that's what the
fight is right the s p 500 is on fire
you literally can't miss it's going to
continue to hit all-time high after
all-time high
because
the second it appears that the market is
going to crash or there's going to be
some sort of correction you literally
are going to get the government and
others stepping in and saying we're
going to use monetary and fiscal policy
to prevent any sort of market correction
or market crash what can they do though
besides they've lowered interest rates
so much that they can only print money
well they could go negative but there's
a religious aspect to going to negative
interest rates uh in the united states
we see in europe and other places
there's negative interest rates so for
sure it's an option you can do it um and
there's people here in the united states
who believe we will go to negative rates
right uh but then they also can use
monetary or fiscal stimulus in terms of
actually um injecting more capital so if
you think of interest rates interest
rates are an incentive right if i allow
the interest rate to drop enough or i
push it down then what it does is it
incentivizes you to come borrow money
because obviously it's cheap capital the
other thing i can do is i can simply
just hand out the cash right so if you
think about the airline industry for
example they got handed 25 plus billion
dollars last year and two-thirds of it
they got to keep for free
right
nobody got any equity there was no
paying it back there's no insurance
there's nothing just here you get the
tens of billions for free on top of that
you then look at things like the housing
market going up and and going nuts right
if you look at the stock market this is
all because of the policy decisions that
are being made
most companies are not better off today
than they were a year ago right there
are some like the technology companies
who have benefited but if you start to
understand what is actually driving this
market it begins to ask the question if
you're a value investor and you've been
a value investor for your entire life
you would look at the multiples in the
market you say this is out of control
there's no way that these valuations are
sustainable we're at uh kind of record
numbers in terms of valuation or some
sort of p e ratios um you know all that
type of stuff
it has to come down it has to revert to
the mean it has to come back to kind of
a normal
valuation framework but i don't think
that that's necessarily true again i
don't know what's going to happen i'm
not a
public stock investor so i don't really
spend that much time kind of thinking
about which stocks to buy which ones
don't which ones are overvalued which
ones aren't but what i do know is that
just because historically that's been
the average doesn't mean we have to go
back there because the thing that's
changed is pre-2008-2009
there was not this appetite for
intervention in markets to have central
banks step into the market and
completely manipulate it back up to
prevent the short-term pain now that we
have this type of appetite
you can see that investors are just
going long like just just get long and
shut up and they're just going to pump
stock prices to the moon and that's what
we're seeing michael saylor understand
in terms of if you're going to do that
to the stock market and other assets and
inflation is going to hit these uh kind
of 10 or 30 year highs i have to do
something with the cash where do i put
it he evaluated all of these
opportunities he put it in bitcoin and
from his first purchase he's up almost
you know 500 percent from even some of
his uh recent purchases he's up and so
for an average price of you know 26 27
thousand dollars have put three billion
dollars to work and to be up you know 20
000 per bitcoin that he's bought
seems to be a pretty good strategy so
far do you think that what we're seeing
now is similar to what we saw in the
financial crisis of 2007.89 so i'm
looking at the p e ratio of s p and it
it basically dipped down to like 17 um
and 21 2008 and 2007 2008 respectively
and we're back up to it went up to 70 in
2009 at the start of 2009 but we're back
up to i think a 38 right now um so is
are we just seeing like did they
manipulate the markets and that's
exactly what they're doing now
so if you go back let's use gold as an
example right in 2008 the summer of 2008
gold dropped 30
there's a liquidity crisis that played
out right we had a housing crisis there
was uncertainty and chaos in the markets
uh so investors got scared they sold
whatever assets they had they sold their
stocks they sold their gold whatever
assets they sold and they wanted dollars
so if you think about almost a weighing
machine to some degree right the asset
gold is denominated in dollars so the
price goes down that means that the
dollar is getting stronger and the gold
you know per ounce is going down so
you're getting a a strengthening dollar
the vice versa happens if the price goes
up the dollar gets weaker and the asset
gets stronger right it's a relationship
between them two
when gold sold off 30
in the summer of 2008 uh the fed stepped
in obviously everyone knows kind of the
global financial crisis story and at the
time it was hundreds of billions of
dollars of stimulus
and so gold then
proceeded between 2008 the bottom of of
that 30 sell-off to 2011 about two and a
half years or so it hit an all-time high
so it took
an entire summer for the liquidity
crisis and then it took two and a half
years for gold to hit an all-time high
as a response to all the stimulus going
through the market et cetera what we got
in 2020
was the exact same mechanism on a highly
compressed time frame so what happened
was in march of 2020
all asset prices were selling off gold
sold off 15 stocks sold off 30 bitcoin
sold off you know 55 or whatever it was
uh and all of a sudden you get the
intervention in the market so the fed uh
you got monetary and fiscal stimulus all
this stuff kind of comes in
immediately there was about a week and a
half two weeks of a drawdown and then it
just skyrocketed and we were back
recovered by the end of april pretty
much we had we had already recovered and
we were off to the races right and so if
you think about the recovery time there
it just happened so much faster and a
lot of that was due to uh
those in power or influence
had a playbook this time they knew okay
if the market uh goes down like this and
we need to instill confidence and we
need to uh solve a liquidity crisis
we're gonna bring like what at the time
i was calling monetary bazookas we're
gonna drop monetary bombs on this
battlefield where there's zero chance
that we're walking out of here with
anything that looks like an economic
crisis surviving like we're literally
just gonna bomb the [ __ ] out of the
economy and what did they do they
literally took every single tool in
their toolbox two emergency rate cuts to
zero percent right
incredible speed and severity uh and
kind of propensity for action they then
said okay we're gonna come out and we're
just gonna start injecting as much
liquidity in the market as we can and so
right now i mean i remember at one point
i said uh they're gonna end up printing
five trillion that the that's what's
gonna end up being
birdie over that
but we may get to 10 trillion remember
the fed's balance sheet in 2008 was 900
billion dollars today it's 8.3 trillion
by the end of the year it's probably
going to come close maybe we don't hit 9
trillion maybe we do we'll see it's 10x
in what 13 years 10 years 12 years
like they were just ready this time and
so when you think about uh the response
the assets have done the exact same
right what happened assets sold off in
2008 and they eventually hit an all-time
high to a couple years but they hit an
all-time high
we got it in a 12-month period basically
and now
the stock market cannot help itself
one out of every three days
of trading in 2021 the s p has hit an
all-time high one out of every five days
of trading the
dow jones has hit an all-time high
crazy i'm sorry i think it's nasdaq yeah
nasdaq 100 i think it's one of every
five days hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it